so some of you leads how are you then
yeah good looking forward to this yeah
no it's just on so
you want to do it live so you'll know
that i suppose the truth you want to say
your version of events you're not like
you know talk to the people and tell
them yeah
i do videos every day yeah i get a lot
of people i get a lot of people
um do videos about me take things out of
context and different things
and i've always said if anyone wants to
chat any people that are going out and
doing
saying i'm a fake guru uh come and tell
me to my face let's do a live interview
usually people don't usually people then
then
then stop because they know that if they
met me to my face
and actually said you're a fake guru
that have no evidence for that
you know people just say it because it's
uh yeah and it's it's a bandwagon
which gets views um it's it
people think oh samuel oh samuel's fake
because they see all my value they see
me doing youtube videos
and they think oh that's great and then
someone comes along and says no it's
fake
which by the way i think is um a really
really
um bad thing to do i think when someone
builds up their reputation by helping
people adding value running a legitimate
business to come and say
that that's fake and they're a fake guru
i think that's really
serious yeah so um how we actually how
this came about actually is simply that
i must have made the video you know
should you do rent to rent
and um individual i must have mentioned
what fate guru and
i flashed the image of him now you go on
contact and i thought you know um
i thought it was a fake account at first
actually i didn't think it was you i
generally
was it you it was me bro so you you had
that long message i saw it
i thought another person saying things
about me
yeah untrue unverified no evidence
and i thought all right cool so i
commented and i said uh hey listen dude
don't try it don't try and tear other
people down
to build yourself up if you've got good
stuff to say then
say that good stuff so i told you i said
don't sell out
absolutely yes but don't get me wrong
though
i'm not building my youtube channel to
take down other people okay that's not
me i'm not
no no but you but you i'm not like other
people well you called me a fake europe
with with no evidence for that okay well
let's begin anyways
he got in contact with me and i thought
you know what why can't i see you face
to face i mean um
what i want to know is you know joey
listen um bbc why don't they
come and see your face's face like
what's up with them i've invited
people that have gone and said stuff
about me with no evidence i've always
made myself available
but but but it's very rare that people
go okay well
let me actually because there's nothing
to say there's nothing like you
but you'll come with nothing like i say
actually you know why am i fake well how
am i a fake
in what way am i a fake guru well tell
me how am i a fake guru
do you even know what a fake you're even
is let's just define it let's start good
idea
what is a your favorite i would like to
start off by saying you know a fake
group could be someone that
you know present themselves as something
they're not
yeah okay yep so for example you'd
present yourself let's say
someone as a guru when you're not yeah
or you say um you know you're a property
investor yeah but you don't do as much
as you say you do
you know okay so like you know if i said
um i invest in
if i'm a millionaire but i'm not i'm i'm
lying i'm a fake guru i'm trying to make
but a guru is a teacher
i mean the definition of a guru is
someone that is is an expert
an expert in in a field or a teacher
that's a guru yeah a fake guru is
someone that pretends to be an expert
teacher that's actually not
so that's a fake guru okay so you said i
was a fake guru
so tell me how much fake europe
how did you just do it for yourself no
no no no i already explained it to your
manager um
i did that for views i got from for
clickbait okay
do you think that's ethical yes it's
difficult everyone does it on youtube
it's youtube so because
okay so because everyone does it you
think it's ethical
it's normal it's not that deep okay but
it's not compared to but i think it's
outrageous
it's not outrageous oh it is if listen
when someone spends their life running a
legitimate business
providing good value teaching people
helping people i'm not i'm not i'm not
arguing that don't get me wrong
okay when someone does that and then
someone else comes along
and says that they are fake which is
untrue we encountered that but carry on
yeah it says okay we can get on to that
but when that's not true
and they don't even think it's true yeah
but to say that ju
to just to try and tear somebody down to
build yourself
up no it's not to build myself up i
don't my channel isn't around
bringing people down okay but you tried
but you said i was a fake guru
it's a one off and you're not the only
person i've called the fake guru well i
can't speak for it for other people i
can just speak for me
when when i provide value trained people
thousands of people when i'm a
legitimate business person
to say and i spend my whole life
building myself up and helping people
building my reputation
and then i have people like you come
along and say he's fake
i can't believe you don't think that's
unethical when you don't even think it
necessarily
do you think it just do you think i'm a
fake guru
thunderstone okay how how many
properties do you own
well well how many do i say you said
that when you say something
how many properties are you and i've
asked the question well i'm a developer
so i've done over 300 property deals
wait 300 property deals
yeah over 300. you've done over 300
tours you do
here's the thing i am exactly what i'm
saying okay
i am exactly what i say i am i i don't
go around saying i own x amount of
houses because okay
that's not what i do okay let's do that
let's find some rules okay
you're in the property in the streets
all that if someone wants to learn from
you they need to um know
that how many properties have you done
so for example over 300 and i package
and sell deals
and i buy and i build i build houses i
just i just built six houses in a joint
venture and sold them
with a guy called trevor but what does
it matter i built six houses
from scratch i bought package and sell
i've done a lot of property deals
and hey everything's going back to my
question
how many properties do you own yeah but
yeah but it changes everything
so you said i know you're standing
outside of houses i keep up with your
content but
i've sold i've sold i've sold dozens of
houses
doing in don costa i've sold a load i've
built and sold houses
well and i okay okay listen now if i
said i own
100 houses but it was what i said about
my credibility that's not true
okay let me get into that so if i want
to learn from someone i expect them to
be
good at what they do yeah sure you agree
yeah now let's talk about your don't
cost a house
you sold that recently for eighty four
thousand pounds you know i i i've sold a
lot but i've sold a lot of houses made a
lot of money
look look you know you you bought it no
you said you bought it so you know
do you know yes or no they don't cut out
i don't know i think there's nothing on
my head when i do not
know about it no but dude last year i
met i'm i turned over
i turned over just shy of 10 million i
made two million
profit everything yeah mostly in
property so
training courses no not training courses
i can show you i can share my company's
house and i can show you my money
i can show you how much yeah no no you
probably injected money i know i know i
know i know okay
okay but listen what do i you said a
fake guru is someone
that says there's something that they're
not what about what do i say to them
okay so
i say i sam experienced property
investors you say you're an expert
in property well i i've where have i
actually said that though
i am an expert probably but what you
have said you are probably you you have
said you're
you i've been in property for 12 years
i've done over 300 deals
i've made millions of pounds on
properties you sold courses you must be
a property expert to do all these things
okay well if you say so right yeah
you say so okay cool you say your
property expert but
for one example the doncaster house you
may have lost on that but
okay but but poker so then why would so
that's that's
this is just one but i'm not even done
we've got to go to the castle
you're going to talk about the castle
are you sure are you sure but let's be
real
let's be honest listen pokey if you if
you've got a business
yeah i i teach this on youtube i say
you're gonna have how you're gonna have
properties you're gonna have staff yeah
you're going to you
can sometimes perform some that perform
and some that underperform so why would
you only try and find out and filter out
the odd property here and there that you
might not think has done well why would
you not look on a hole
how much money i've made how i'm doing
like i prefer
i i'll rather prefer but you just come
out and be clean about it okay
okay i'm cleaning about what that's why
we're doing this that's what we're doing
think about what
just some of the elves you may have
taken in the past i don't like the way
that um
you keep changing like the facts and
figures so you'll say
name on never factor figures i've
changed in 2019
you said in one video that you bought 29
properties yep
you then go to change it but you've been
involved in 29 property transactions
okay maybe some of them will enjoy
adventures and stuff okay
you need to be strict and like straight
with the audience because a lot of
people like to pick
that fact but dude listen you said i'm a
fake guru
all i say is i i i as you just said
every year
i talk about what i've done that year i
talk about i do videos and say some
overperform some underperform
some perform some of my deals have gone
great some have not done great
overwatch's done really well
so would you say truthful yes so just be
truthful then why can't i just be
truthful to you but dude
this is outrageous coming from somebody
that has a property course
like you have your friends a free
property course by the way it's not 12
grand
yeah but dude most of my courses are
free nearly all of my students don't pay
me any money
that's true i agree so so you
have a property course like i have a
property course
ah a free property course i've done over
300 deals i made millions of pounds of
elevation look at
that and by the way by the way
self-elevation
that's exactly right my whole mission
it's not even about me look at my
students
i'm about lifted out of the students i'm
not saying i'm
i'm not discriminating the work you've
done like i admit you've every single
week i would say in terms of like the
property industry you've helped and
growing it for sure okay i fully agree
so so so when i have trained
thousands of property investors i've
made millions of pounds myself but look
at my students
let me finish they've become financially
free and i run a training course and
nearly all of my content is free
and and you're running a property course
i mean geez what what do
how many deals have you how many pro how
many problems do you own okay firstly
let's not switch onto myself i'm
interviewing you no no but you're the
person that said i was a fake
guru which actually i think is ironic
because i think you're the epitome of
the fake guru
well you're doing youtube videos talking
about property you you even say oh how
to get on the property ladder
you know even on the property ladder
rental rent is a business model which
you are aware of
of course which helps you develop
networking and connections
within so for example if i wanted to get
on the property ladder
i now have the connections to i now know
rent to rent is a transferable school i
can use registration
you do videos yes how to get on the
property ladder
you're not on the problem okay can we
finish everything i say i've done i've
done
some of my deals have gone well some of
them have gone really well some of them
have gone bad
cool okay and i'd say that i do okay
okay but samuel
do you agree you you market it in a way
where you make it seem a little bit too
easy
just to gain more quality that's very
subjective
no money down deals do you think you
create that time no money down deals
i don't think i'll create the chance but
you you're using so much
i think you're a fake guru i'm not
there's evidence because i'll give you
the evidence
you did a video called how to get on the
property ladder and you're not on the
property ladder
you call me a fake guru dude i'm gonna
be funny but if you were my student i'd
be embarrassed
right because you haven't done anything
bro you're
wait
i'm trying to just be the middleman okay
i'm trying to
get you called me yes just you not not
that you
clip clickbait okay okay so but you so
you said something that you didn't
mean look this is you know that you're a
yes or no too nice i told you test i
already told you just turn this down
but you you you said that we need to
define the definition of fake europe
yeah and then you should be able to say
yes or no so am i a fake guerra
yes okay how am i figure because
you might we define fake europe it's
someone that's an expert or a teacher
yeah and then so am i pretending to be
to be a to be to be a good teacher or to
be am i pretending to be
to be a teacher no no no fake you're
within the property industry
so you're pretending to be like a fake
property expert
essentially okay so so so firstly let's
begin
let's let's begin let's begin now
because all i did no you just said
something that's not true
you said that i'm pretending to be
probably expect all i do is document and
vlog my journey
and document and vlog my students
journeys so
how's that being fake are you saying
that when i say i was not i don't see
that's not fake
name one example when i've said i've
done this or i've done that my students
done this when it hasn't been true
i'm not saying i'm not discrediting you
for the work you've done for your
students
so how am i fake gary then you act
in a certain way where you act in a
certain way where you basically
market rent to rent property to the
vulnerable people unfortunately okay so
so on market so now
if you're saying like i don't market to
any people i just put youtube videos out
i put youtube videos out same as you put
videos out the only difference between
me and you is
i put youtube videos out on stuff that
i've actually done you put youtube
videos out of stuff that you've never
done
what have i never done well you you you
ha you have a property course where you
teach hmos and you do
have i've been wanting to run for how
many how many twitters have you done
one and how did it go when it was okay
did it you still got it
yeah that's not what you said on youtube
well you said you said on youtube that
you got rid of it because of the
pandemic no i'm planning to get rid of
it i'm planning to get rid of it i'm
planning to get so you've got one rent
to rent that's gone so badly that you're
planning to get rid of it what are the
deals have you done
so you don't want five no no wait no
wait one failed deal whatever no wait
first of all
you you understand what's going on the
pandemic you and i'm doing very well
very very well so my students my student
service accommodation deals are
continued to go over maybe if you've
done my training
maybe you'd be maybe that rent to rent
no you know what and maybe you wouldn't
have
no no no no no you've been warming
during the fight sam you sam you
something you are you are going well
overboard let me explain to you no
i'm saying you're a fake guru but you're
dasty say i'm a fake guru i document my
journey and talk honestly and openly
about my figures
you lie and say you're on the property
ladder when you're not position yourself
no no no
no by having a property no no no no wait
wait first of all
me i'm documenting my journey just like
you are yesterday if i am
what you have a property course bro yes
because i've gone into rent
i've done rental rates you failed
inventory i didn't fail enrichment i'm
teaching others how to get onto rent to
rent no one felt
normal come on you told me let me know
if you actually watched the video
i watched it i watched them i did my
diligence
yeah before they started just to say i
hope you're ready because boy
right look so you did hold on you did
one minute to rent deal that you're now
giving back because you said on youtube
that was losing
300 pounds a month because of the
pandemic that's family
yeah okay so you've done one minute
tomorrow that's never made money it's
lost money
it made profit and then the pandemic
came i took i got like a free month let
so just so how much money did you make
overall don't lie because of course
we're going to fat check afterwards how
much money did you make overall on that
rental rent
i still want you to check out my account
you're not sure but on youtube you said
you were losing 300 pounds a month
yeah no no that was australian from
april to
july when did you get the rental rent
what month february so just before so
you got it in february just before just
for the passenger you got the rent to
rent in february right
then first of all i'm interviewing you
no we're having a discussion are this
interview
because it's people like you fake gurus
that have property courses that have no
property experience
they say you're on the property they
should be ashamed of yourself that go
out and clickbait
unashamedly no no no no no no no
wait do you understand the youtube game
you understand the youtube game it's all
about cutback it's all about game views
it's all about dragon clicks yes it is
i've seen youtube videos you talk about
how it's a business you make money from
it you get clicks from it
i don't do that you do no no i don't
have ads on my channel i teach for free
why why don't you have advantages
because i don't care i just vlog my
journey
teach for free give free books free
youtube videos
99 of my customers don't give me any
money they watch me for free you on the
other hand are trying to get every
single penny
are calling people fake gurus when
they're not i'm lying on your videos to
try and generate traffic
no no no no no no no and then have your
dad no no no no
no no no no no no no no no no i'm not
lying in my videos
i'm not deceiving you i'm telling the
truth no you're not
you're lying on your
you've done you're on the property
ladder when you're not you've said you
you've made yourself i
never saw the problem the videos you did
how to get on the problem
all right all right so you say how to
get on the property i didn't mention the
word i didn't mention we're on a
property ladder individually so you're
doing a video saying how to get on the
property ladder and each and and the
video is done by you who's not on the
property
i would call that fake guruism no it's
not it is because you're
you're teaching people but you're fake
look
and then you have your okay okay okay
cool cool cool let's
first you think i'm a fake hero yes to
understand how i think
i'm about to go i'm going to get on to
that so look let's let's
walk me through your journey you want me
to tell you my journey you go with
myself to 17.
i can tell you my journey yeah okay i'll
give you i'll give you a 60 second or
something version
okay cool no so you got your first house
at 17 correct
how do you do that teacher i want to
know i want to learn well you need to
learn because you know no no i'm not i'm
because when i was your age i was a lot
more successful you're 20 years old next
month right
yeah i have multiple properties that i i
actually had invested in i'm making
sure how did you learn though how did
you learn that i went on training
courses
how much do you pay 12 grand i paid a
lot of money did you pay your 12 grand i
paid more than 12 grand
really yep and i went on courses from
people who i was almost didn't go on
do you know why i almost didn't go on
the courses well because people were
calling them fake gurus and i almost was
scared off
thank god i didn't listen just like you
calling people fake gurus with no
evidence
in your own words to try and get views i
think that's unethical i think it's
wrong i think you should be saying to
yourself
do you think you're unethical i don't
think i'm an ethical no i think you're
unethical
so you don't think you know getting
people that already have debt
yeah in their name to pay get into more
debt yeah to buy your course you don't
think that's something i think their
business be honest with be honest be
honest with you
here's how business works
you clearly don't know no no no but do
you think i'm asking you do you think
it's unethical for someone some of us
already
to get more debt okay of course i'm a
teacher our business works you have a
willing seller and a willing buyer
i only sell my courses to people that
are willing to buy and i only sell it at
the price i'm willing to sell it that's
called
business you call yourself a serial
entrepreneur how are you serial
entrepreneur
you call it you do property courses
outside of the fail
your due diligence is not that great oh
yeah it is your due diligence
it's not because fake you are on your
website of your training company
it says terms and conditions in the name
of poku banks limited
pokey banks limited doesn't even exist
bro
i can show you the screenshots look have
you got a company called pokebank's
limited no the reason why is because why
did you put it on your website
banks can't be used to creating a
company is that it was poker state
okay but why did you on your website put
poku banks limited
in your terms you're moving away from
the questions no no
no
do you think you are unethical no so you
think it is it's not unethical to sell
courses for people that cannot afford
them already
i think that you have if you're already
in debt do you think it's you have to
have a willing buyer and a willing
seller
and i think do you know is that not how
business works all the time
if you go and buy if you go and buy
anything any product if you're going to
buy a car if you buy a house you buy
anything
is that not just is that just not but
we're talking about a course which is
going to teach you how to get financial
freedom but
most nearly all of my training is for
free and then people that love it and
want to do more
so so then in my opinion right
in my opinion you were complaining no
like no stop stop in my opinion right if
i was to sell course to someone by the
way this
is why people don't come and meet me
face to face why because they get owned
no because i'm not done good there is
i'm loving it look because
no no no no no no no look look so if you
have a course
12 grand or 10 grand plus a vet i don't
have a course for 12 grand
or 10 grand plus that how's house coffee
been treating the training business
i've still got lots of students it's
great but nearly all of my students they
don't pay me anyway so
it's all free so when the revenue has
gone down a little bit well here's how
my training works
nearly all of it is free yeah then if
you want then youtube books
courses free so everyone can do for free
then you can pay 95 pound a month and
you can receive coaching
and mentoring unlimited mentoring
coaching for 95 pounds a month
so how how does that change from the 12
grand like i don't know because i don't
have a single course for 12 grand
you just wait you used to nope never had
it
never had it 10 grand plus
i put them on the way i can't remember
the exact month they didn't use debate i
regret not because people make stuff up
like you
no i'm doing you fat so you tell me i'll
tell you hey here's my way so you're
telling me none of your courses were
worth 10 grand plus that is that
returning time no never
let me tell you this though she's really
important she's really important
if you do all of my courses okay you can
spend
10 grand plus that plus if you do all of
them so that's not the
top one year thing so you have so this
is the tears it's like five tiers
everything's free to begin with you can
go on youtube crash course
it's all free then if you want you can
pay 95 pound a month and you can receive
mentoring coaching
weekly calls 365. yeah let me explain
what that weekly calls with me
unlimited mentoring calls training wait
wait wait unlimited menu yeah
with with me on my team but then when
peop but then lots of people
have given you bad reviews saying you
know they can't get in contact with you
you're not replanting it why
why is that i personally feel like
you've gone name one person
name one person that said that look i
don't i don't care about it so you can't
even give one person oh look
let me tell you something one of the
analysis from you i personally feel like
you are the biggest give me facts give
me facts don't give me your best
i'm even about to compliment you and
discuss moving me look
you are the biggest property guy in the
uk you agree
yep you're trying to probably yeah you
know you i
think yeah and the reason the biggest is
on the best
and the reason the biggest is because i
have more success students than any
other property training company
on the on the planet probably definitely
in the uk that's why that's why people
want to do my training
you think you're bigger than the
american guys no i don't think i'm
bigger i don't think i'm bigger i'm
friends with grant cardone yeah
you called him a fake guru too yeah but
i'm not going to go there and defend him
but he's not that guru yeah
i respect but you called him a fake guru
for views which is unethical by the way
wait so you think selling of course the
song that is already in debt is not
undifficult
there's a difference between willing
seller willing by is that how big all
business is done
you stop going back to the definition
straight i'm really sorry
i can't believe you talk about morals
then you lie on youtube if you're trying
to
get
yourself people down your audacity to
talk about morals
when i'm just saying winning seller
willing buyer click bait is normal on
youtube okay you know that
please please thumbnails funnels your
question is it okay
to say something that is not true is it
okay to sell a course or something
is it okay to say something because it's
okay it's so close to someone's already
is it okay well what do you what do you
suggest the alternative is did you turn
away anymore
should you say someone's already that i
think you should check like
their system check their circumstances
before you know pressure selling them or
whatnot that's what we do what we do is
we run free courses
they come along and they can see if they
like it then they can pay a pound and
spend seven days getting coached and
mentored which they do
and then no no no it's crash course then
the two grand cause it's not there's no
one pound
it's crash course two grand ten grand so
that's that's the
it's not one pound so so they try before
they buy they get loads of value
the crash course and if they want to
spend a couple grand the crash course
are real yeah it's good value that's
great it's good to grab people
and so is all my training and that's why
my students are happy
you know what um my students are very
happy i personally feel like
you just got too big where you couldn't
individually
why do you feel like give me some
evidence give me something like that no
no not bigger than
we use the person isn't bigger than like
give me some facts give me some evidence
you have 170 subscribers on youtube
you're big
you have to over thousand followers on
tick tock you should be responsible and
not lie on your feet
no no no no no no no i'm not saying no
no no no
it's nice i'm trying to talk to you
but when i spend my entire life
adding value giving free content yeah
i respect that i'm not getting on to you
for that right free content like listen
like every single week i have someone
coming on my show talking about how
they've had their finances changed their
lives changed my respect
every single day i have changed the way
people think about money
yeah i'm helping people actually get on
the property ladder you need you need
the training by the way i'm helping out
i would give i would go and probably
without you i'm sorry yeah what you'll
do though
is you'll be trying you'll end up being
trained by my students
no i'll be trained by your competitors
now you'll be trained bonus students by
your competitors you're not good enough
to even be a student
i'll be embarrassed to have you on my
show embarrassing look
wait wait wait but but then you are you
are worried about what i have to say
about you
you don't care about my opinion
you have thousands of views on youtube
when you say things that are not true
and you lie and you call me a fake guru
you're allowed way more than me
to name one time i've lied oh my geez
just kidding
many times you've learned to tell them
your lies
my allies are nothing compared to your
lives your lives your lives have
you i mean you can't even give me one
time i can give you many you've lied
hey rest in peace to daniel
oh my god so now one time i've lied your
liars have
because you're very unfactual you're
alive
your lives unfortunately have committed
you know do you think
yep the suicide was anything related i
think that's outrageous thing to say
there's no evidence for it the bbc
didn't say that the telegraph didn't say
that
you're saying otherwise okay but i think
it's an outrageous thing to say
the telegraph said that there was no
suggestion there's any link you have no
problem
it's despicable it's tips it's
disgusting there's no link whatsoever
and again
i know you like to go on emotion and i
know you've got to but there's no
evidence for that whatsoever and it's
not rage you should be ashamed for
saying that no and you should be ashamed
you look you have done more worse than
me tell me
you have gone way more worse can you
tell me why what i'm bad
you've put people into so much amounts
of debt you've been okay i have a
personal experience with you
i went to a crash course this time last
year yep now during the break
when um i think you you only send people
to the back
i was just i think i was on the phone to
agents one of your tasks you set i was
on the phone to agent
and um there was two somalian brothers
and they were
they're scrabbling to get money to buy
the course okay but um they couldn't get
it
and um you know obviously you came
around thinking oh you know why didn't
you buy it they don't have the money and
you asked them
and i was there obviously you don't
remember me but obviously i remember you
yeah you asked them to get along
don't you think
is from your youtube videos you post one
video every day give me one lie i've
said then
i can give many lies you've said you
look
you are trained here's the crazy thing
poco yeah
what's your david david your name right
berkey banks does you know david though
berkey banks
but is it david pokey banks okay so you
think it's okay to call me scammy wall
but then when i call you david your real
name you seem like you don't like it why
is that
no it's not that i don't like it just
call me poker banks that's just you know
but you can't even call me samuel
and you think it's okay to call you
scammy when i call you david this is
your real name
look what's the timber frame yo
this is pathetic dude what's the
difference because i just built six
houses look
look look all the evidence is in your
video i feel like you you're uploading
so much that you conduct yourself so
when did i lie when did i do anything on
everything
why did you call me scammy what did i do
it was a scam this was a it's a running
joke like you're calling here's
everything it's also a running joke is
everything
your uh your property training course
how can you have the audacity
yeah to call me a sham or a scam and i'd
look what you're scaring me
you just call me scamming no no no not
my property course no you just did it
then
just now yeah yeah but i i i'm not doing
it you have the audacity
to run a property training course okay i
run a property training because three
which is free just free and so
doesn't matter if it's free or if it's
not you're setting yourself up as an
expert by running a property training
course yeah to the younger generation
yeah okay it doesn't matter you're
running a property training course
when you're not on the property
get on to that it hasn't no but no but
where was the last time did renovation
on that castle
dude was last time when was last time
when was the last time just say just say
it
so just answer the question don't don't
go around there like you always try to
do
let's say i've not done renovation on it
for a year okay
right let's say that is the case
interest payments boy
but what does that mean but you're
trying to make fun of me i'm not trying
to make fun of you you're trying to get
at me i'm going i'm
getting back to you you said i was a
fake guru no and i'm not i'm saying
you're a figure
am i a fake guru because because
because what why why am i faking it
okay you do you're not okay look
you're not as big of a problem but you
you say you are
okay well i just say that you i just say
what i'm doing so
so you had you know all your properties
in your personal name
as a property expert it would make sense
for you to have them
in a company why you know interested
what year did section 24 come in a new
team
sorry around 2018 around wonder
commandant
what year did section i'm asking you
when did you come in no because you just
asked me
why i ran my companies that i have so
i'm asking you when did section 24
okay cool you know because you're a fake
guru you teach property but don't know
no no i teach you when to rent i don't
know i don't teach hmos
which is a rental rent strategy have you
done it there yes
where did you do it i've done it with
people i've source i've sourced with
other people
so you've source deals i've sourced with
like of course
with her i'm not gonna i can't say i'm
not saying i'm live but i've sourced
with
i've sourced a hmo with someone yeah but
uh but rental rent
hatred for your business part of the
dead as well no no do you do the
property training course with
by the way denzel who is your the guy
you've run your training with
right demsel came to my crash course
said it was great denzel yeah
i've been to a crash course in that
series denzel
recommends james armstrong as a mentor i
i like i like gene
he's a great mentor he's always
struggling but he knows everything from
me yeah
no you i'm not so i'm not sure look
i think you know what it is you are my
student student you are my mentee's
mentor
no no no no no no no james armstrong's
your mentor right
i haven't paid them i don't but you list
him as a mentor on your when you're i
don't know
denzel denzel does no no on the side
it says it says james armstrong is our
property mentor and then when i ask you
what deals you've done you said i've
done them with people i've been with
people
basically you're full of crap basically
you list james armstrong as your mentor
look bro
that bro this is james armstrong
he's my success student i mean i got i
got i got hundreds of them and they're
your mentors
and and that's not my mentor i don't ask
james about him ask him if i know but
dan but you ever done any deals
maybe if you paid maybe if you paid
james no maybe you'd have done more
deals no
maybe who's more successful you or
denzel jones about property
no this is about you don't trust me okay
i'm interviewing you please are we
talking about fake heurism
please successful you will your denzel
please relax see your
answer i'm not gonna answer because this
is mean to me in you now that's what i'm
saying
the reason people don't come to face to
face is because people like you they say
things that aren't true and then when
they come in they have no evidence and
they look stupid like you look stupid
now
i don't look stupid well i think you
look very stupid because you said i was
a fake guru but it turns out that you
are credit my students as your mentor
wait i've done retrofit so therefore i
have the
you know what you believe yeah i have
the credibility to share my experience
and
i didn't you handed the keys back
because it wasn't making money you're
losing 300 pounds a month
why would someone you say this i've
heard you say this you say
learn from someone you want to switch
places with right i heard you say that
who when you're running a property
course who would want to switch places
with you right now in property i'll tell
you who
no one no i've got the knowledge which
it doesn't stay there i think i can get
yourself
no but first of all let me get i'll be
okay to teach something with the
knowledge but or do you just teach
things second hand because you came to
my crush course
no i didn't i didn't know i didn't think
you're not teaching off your own
experience yes it is because i've done
the essay i'm teaching my
you didn't go through it's free but i've
seen it i've literally yeah it sucked
that means that means your stuff sucks
this guy's just saying that because i'm
younger than him
nothing to do with that age and
everything to do with lies everything to
do with you saying
you're a fake guru buddy i've got a ring
the way you talk around the question
i'll go i'll go admit i'm gonna talk
around the questions you do
i've asked you something ask me a
question out right there tell me what
what lie i've said tell me why i'm a
fake guru
tell me give me any evidence look give
me evidence
i'd love to hear it samuel
i'm going to ask you again so again back
to the property expert thing
why when people search up you know for
hammy houses yeah
they want to know because you know if
you're a property expert they would like
to know okay cool if he has three houses
okay i trust him i'll invest in him yeah
why is it that like there's only a few
houses on company's house i know someone
in your personal name but then it
doesn't make sense okay we'll go back
i'll go back to that
okay which because you didn't you don't
clearly know
wait wait wait by the way this is not
just for me this is for yeah but i want
to see
okay but by the way i've spoken about
this all this many times but again
so so two they brought section 24 in
2016.
so prior to 2006 and they phased it in
until 2020. i started my property
journey i bought my first house 2009.
yeah all my properties i was buying from
2009 onwards how much was the first one
the first house i bought for 100 000
pounds
is you see simon it's it's 21a
maryvale road in bourneville i bought it
for a hundred thousand pounds
but some was what's the issue man i i
want to like you but like
the lies are just in your videos so in
one video you said you bought for a
youth
yeah i made a discrepancy one time about
one about the night and when another
[ __ ]
i guess of course you said you bought
120 years no i refinanced it
maybe maybe
i do a video every single day and i talk
about my houses all that i've bought
maybe if you watch every single video
and you're trying to find discrepancies
that people do
you might be able to find one time or
two tons where i where i set a figure
this relates to the fake guru okay no
but if someone's true
21 ammo vote check it out twenty-one
over road in bournemouth i still own it
today
it's made me two hundred thousand pounds
i bought it when i was 17 years old and
i was
so i bought i bought that property 21am
over the road i bought it uh below
market value
i refinanced it back up to its true
value i did it in my stepdad's name he
didn't give me any money
i did it myself based on the knowledge
that i've had from saving up paper
rounds as a kid
and using that money to go on training
programs nice and then that's how i
bought my first then they changed the
rules yeah and they started doing lease
option agreements
deal packaging yeah and i built up a
large property portfolio 20
years old i was um i was making six and
a half thousand pounds a month
when i was your age well next month how
much how much six and a half thousand
pounds a month
twenty years old i think it's been three
years i think no but bear man though i'm
not twenty years so i feel like i might
overtake you but if you do then
congratulations but with your
yeah congratulations if you do but let
me tell you something a little bit of
advice
yeah when you're when your your business
is called self-elevate
yeah software self-help i believe in
lifting other people up
and when you and when you do things like
call people fake yours which is not true
you have no facts for
like grandchildren your videos are the
facts your videos are defects
because there was a discrepancy between
the household no but then you've done it
multiple times
look cool then one other time because
what you do is you come out with big
statements but you can't back it up
no it's not that i can't back it up well
it's all there on the internet
now do you think your courses are worth
talking absolutely i think so
but back up what you just said but i
think say things aren't
right okay okay do you think there's a
there's an issue of under delivery
you don't think that um sometimes you
know when people try to get in contact
with you
like for help because there's pen to
people like even glenn you you
ignore their messages no even after the
glenn said in the interview you know
when you and glenn were doing that um
yeah um after yeah
um like like this yes he said that you
know ignoring messages and whatnot i
thought you got two dudes
i helped him make over 50 000 pounds of
bloody brooklyn up
with no money from scratch he did a
lease option agreement
he got multiple deals and then
afterwards we exchanged over 100
messages he didn't pay me
he then moaned online and said that he
couldn't get hold of me and he was
struggling
so so how does that make my uh customer
service bad or me
one other where i actually have dropped
give me one trust power i don't look at
their names
trust pilot literally go and trust pilot
there's so many people
and there's plenty of people that have
made visuals on land yeah like yeah send
them a fake euro with no facts so give
me one point
wait wait first guys the video where i
couldn't affect guru has
nothing to do with him it's just simply
called you entering and that's what most
people
most people just maybe just fully
dedicated to you have you seen them but
but there's a lot you said and i respond
to them you said i was a fake guru
and you and i actually i didn't even say
no i hope you know i didn't actually say
you was a fake girl yeah you did did i
say my my mouth yes there's a lot of
fake gurus and then a picture of me
flying up so i didn't say my
i didn't say it with my words cool okay
okay cool
but anyways i'll come here to tell you
as well now
so you're saying oh yeah you're telling
me about people that are uh unhappy my
students
even on trustpilot trustpilot on google
you'll see i've got four stars
my students have independent have
independent feedback firms
and and we we just ran an event uh last
week
it was called the deal selling
masterclass there's 19 people in the
room
how much they have paid they all paid uh
2 000 pounds do you
let me pay 2 000 yep 2 000 pounds
19 hold on let me just say my point 19
people were there they all paid 2 000
pounds
yeah during those two days people were
making money
on the program all right everybody that
left filled out an independent feedback
form
17 of them gave us a 10 out of 10 and
two of them gave us an eight out of ten
so you talk about are my training
programs good do i deliver
well that's not my opinion that's not
your opinion that's just the fact
okay that's so i swear i agree so you
agree with my training i do deliver my
training
but then this you see i feel like where
it is with you right
you have your five star reviews banging
five stars but then the one star reviews
it's just like you can't ignore it so
it's just like why
i feel like review is either five
there's no three four two i feel like
it's just five or one
do you do you agree i don't know
if that is the case though what does
that maybe i've got a marmite
personality
maybe some people but here's the thing
but five is the biggest
five five stars is the biggest but the
vast majority of my
students actually do my training yeah
over 90 percent of them
leave raving independent reviews yeah
i agree so so you talk about my training
is it unethical is it normal no but
okay now when i talk about unethical now
it's the way you sell it i personally
feel like you should change a little bit
i know
maybe a little bit less money for you
but i personally feel like you know for
example
you seem to be you've seen the bbc of
course i've abolished them
yeah so i saw that um
i do believe i do believe that bbc had
an agenda yeah and they take things out
of
context
yeah yeah but it's just like for example
when they had the secret camera i felt
like that was
bad wrong of them but um you know they
the lady was saying um
you know uh i only i don't have any
money
you could i mean i think someone said um
can you raise the limit don't you feel
like it's a little bit uncomfortable no
the thing is
because you're basically telling someone
to get into debt so don't have money
yeah to then get your course yeah
and property let's be real now you need
money not contracts whoever i know you
can be creative but the average person
can't be
it's not as creative i'm sorry you need
knowledge that the average person is
i think yeah you think everyone's like
you you think everyone's as good as you
i think that's what you
believe i don't self-elevate like you do
i elevate other people
and i believe in other people i bring i
bring prosperity of other people
as you see wow i don't know any of your
students i'm not seeing them
yeah i don't put them on the line i'm
not because i'm i'm not as big as you
though that's why i'm
always and furthermore the goal is
successful by the way still call me a
fake girl
by the way the courses i sell are around
49 pounds this is cheap
yeah because it's all about supply and
demand no no no no
it's fine demand business is this about
how much i think the course is worth
your competitiveness 12 courses you tell
people to get into debt no no i don't i
don't say that
no i don't i i say i went into debt no i
didn't i went into debt
and and there's good debt and bad debt
and i agree and some people should get
into debt
some people should get it depends on the
person here's the thing
because everyone's an adult and they
have to make up their own mind if it's
for them or not
but based on all the free stuff you as a
you as an expert
should be there to advise them how can i
say to somebody you shouldn't do it you
should do it you this you can judge
people all i do here's the thing you see
the money
here's the thing of course of course
because i don't blame you everybody no
every business has a willing seller and
a willing buyer
right you've said yourself that my
training is good my students are happy
so what's the problem 99 of my students
don't pay me a penny
what's the issue here buddy no no i
don't why call me a fake boy
look i'm not talking the usual stuff i
commend you that that's that's
there's nothing wrong with that youtube
stuff's great the paid stuff's great
even
much greater gets rave reviews a lot of
people like to say
you can find the law of it it's just
regular educated information
that's not true it's just a symbolically
accurate cool it's not true
if it's not true it's cool i'm not i'm
not going to argue that no no but listen
if that was the case why would my
students be so happy
no that's true it's just the one stop
this is the one starting yeah but the
one yeah but
there's always it's a big big difference
i've got thousands of
reviews every business is going to have
good reviews and bad reviews that's true
and all i can do is i agree i agree
all i can do is deliver good quality
training teach people what
i've done for my own experience not like
your fake courses they're not fake
but you haven't got property experience
i have got properties to rent a
spreadsheet but they want to ask you you
say oh it's been done
different people's names and i can't
talk about it and talk to me about your
other deals
i told you right now no i know this i'm
interviewing you please please
because you can't ask hey let me no no
no no no no no no no so let me ask you
now
do you make more money from training or
property i meant more money from
from property considerably i don't even
take a salary from training there was a
time at one point what
what so you ask me questions i answer
you very legitimately with facts and all
you do is smile
i'm shocked you're doing this you do
know people can pick this apart and just
don't be doing people everything i'm
saying is factual it's going to be a
video it'll be you saying this
and then they'll be your youtube video
contradiction i hope you know that's
coming afterwards and it will also come
about you but the reason though
you can't answer my questions because
you know that we'll fact-check
this is about you confronting some this
is about you okay well tell me what i've
done wrong tell me tell me
again so you think you make more money
off property i don't take a salary from
property
[Music]
your training business let me tell you
something so your property business
makes more than your
training business is that what you're
telling me yeah i make more money from
property i don't take i see i no no no
no
no i'm not talking about take a salary
i'm talking about because you probably
buy stuff in your campaign
right now actually
i want to mention one more thing about
the training point because can i just
say real quick
for the first four years of my training
company being set up for the first four
years i didn't make a penny
from training i started teaching the
back end of 2013.
yeah i set up a little uh training
company called training kings
started off as a sole trader and then i
i registered the company for four
years i made no money from training
was it because
no money from training i started after
four years
um i started to make money from training
and actually
uh 2000 and back end of 2018 my brother
came onto the business
russell russell and he structured the
training business
and um from 2018 2019 my training
business started making a lot of money
and there was a point in time
where there was more monthly cash flow
coming from training then there was cash
flow coming from property but i've
always held much more wealth
in property okay okay okay right now
okay 2020. this year our training
business right now is not making any
money
covered no profit not just covered
making any
let me just finish because we don't
charge that much because they're clever
no no it's right no it's because the
reason you don't charge monsters because
you can't see them face to face to
pressure okay okay
we're running our academy events right
now we just ran the deal selling
masterclass
yeah in a small 30 people right we're
not making money from training i'm still
doing a video every single day
every week let me finish every single
week i'm still having success students
come in
because i do it because i absolutely
love doing it and it's part of my
mission
i'm very successful in property i'm also
a very successful property trainer
and if you want to call me a guru or
whatever call me one thing that i am not
and it outrages me that people say is i
am not fake
everything i started from scratch i'm
working class boy
i bought my first property at 17 years
old in my stepdad's name i've built
everything myself from scratch
now i teach people now i have hundreds
of people are becoming financially clear
and when people like you
okay listen look come along to my course
and that your business partner denzel
then go and do a course and i've got
messages from your business partner
denzel by the way
messaging me saying last year saying can
i come and work for you for free
do you know this no it doesn't matter it
doesn't matter
but i'm not no no really no no it
doesn't matter
it doesn't it doesn't it doesn't matter
it doesn't matter
i don't know why you're bringing them
into it so because you run a property
course together with denzel
not a rent-a-rank course man please yeah
straight you went from right deal
rent to rent i'll show you i'll show you
the contents if you want to see the
content sure
they they know the content right south
florida check that out and
you even you even reference um you even
reference oh bother these are my i won't
show them you right now but these are my
six new bills i just built from scratch
that made over half a million pound
profit
so will you go into the details on the
vigil yeah i i'm doing i'm i've just
done a video about this right now
okay so okay cool so you said to me
earlier
my essay failed so therefore yeah you
shouldn't be teaching
people like you shouldn't be teaching
property there's denzel
there's him asking me to your business
who you do the property course if you're
asking can i work for you this is last
year can i work with you
yeah but that's not the wrong thing
but there is something wrong with though
is after that you then saying i'm a fake
guru
there's something really wrong with that
i've told you it's for clickbait you
know the youtube game okay
how would you think clickbait is like
it's not here's the thing right
how would you feel if you had people
saying that you were you were fake and
it wasn't true
in your case it would be true i do get
hit as well
don't get wrong if you
had legitimately built yourself up and
you've achieved a lot and you're helping
people and teach people
and people would there was a smear
campaign yeah yeah
and people were jumping on the bandwagon
like you jumped yeah
doing videos
i still have people even after putting
out all the evidence after
go you know you go on company's house
you can see millions
you can see my success students every
week i've i've put everything out there
but i still have people like you
saying i'm a fake girl okay so for me to
get on the property
should i get the house cash or mortgage
what do you think
i think you i think you need to start
getting educated no i'm it's good
cash or mortgage cash cash or mortgage
would depend
depends it depends it's just like
[Music]
land that you just saw i bought that all
cash with my own money
number okay i've got over a million
pounds
that's over a million pounds in there
you know people gonna chop this up
yeah okay that's true people in your
youtube videos you've said
you've told and instruct people not to
buy with cash maybe you should say
it depends on the situation you should
add that on after because you know
people gonna chop this up and then just
you know they're gonna well that's why i
did this live because you would have
been the kind of person that would chop
it up
you have bigger haters that you have
haters that will they'll go through this
laughing
and they'll chop it up they'll chop it
up they'll take it out of context
and and for their own ends like you for
your own ends saying things that aren't
true we've never
been trying to just clickbait is
generally normal
you've been a bigger you've been you've
been using clickbait for me and my staff
and my family and my business it's not
clickbait it's
mean it's wrong look
how about this yeah just to be honest
how many properties i've done over 300
deals i don't keep properties now i sell
one so you saw them all
well i've obviously missed them every
month it changes
every month it changes tonight and i
never do videos saying hey i'm samuel
leeds and i own
this many houses because i'm a developer
by package i sell i flip i fix up
i have lease options i have joint
ventures all over the place for me to
give you just go all right
that's why i don't ever hook people in
but i feel like i feel like i feel like
they'll help for your credibility
i'm trying to i think my credibility is
this is how people i'm i'm
that's how people see you now so i'm
like i'm the guy that i said are you
questioning my
experience in property a little bit man
because it's just like
okay well listen listen it's just a
conditions in your videos okay well
listen if you don't think i'm qualified
enough to teach
then simple don't do my course i've been
pro i've been investing in property for
12 years
i've done over 300 deals i've bought
i've done brrs i've done flips i've
packaged and started and lease options
i've been rent to rent i've done lease
options to the very end
i've made millions of pounds in property
that's not if you don't think that's
enough they're fine i'm not going to try
and package up with something that's not
i'm just going to say this is what i've
done and i'm also going to talk about my
students
my students yeah actually my students
every single week they're making
tangible money in their jobs
how am i fake look at ask questions
never am i a fake guru though
look i've told you this it's your
youtube videos your youtubes will be the
death of you it will be but you said
that my youtube videos are really good a
minute ago
yeah but it's just you post so much
where you contradict yourself
no and that name one contradiction
so it's not not castle i've never i'd
vlog it
i've vlogged in the whole thing let's
talk about a castle you took a picture
yeah i'll tell you about it
i don't i don't i don't think there's
anything wrong with it i can't believe
that you oh no no no no
wait what you think it's gonna do it no
no it's just
shocking for someone like you to say
when you when you're getting trained by
my students
i don't do but you credit i'll show you
this poker i'll show you this you say
it's jointly made he it's not me
i'll ask him if i've if he even knows me
all right
what made you more successful okay
that's the question did this house come
from revenue from courses
or are they complete no no no no no let
me let me tell you what i think man
okay i think denzel's a lot more
successful than you
you didn't know what video did you i've
watched it yet so i asked
you as you won't tell me i have to
assume or you can tell me don't do the
same
i'll tell you no no he's more successful
no it's not even how do you even
who's making more money who's making
more money in property you or denzel
denzel okay cool the reason denzel's
making more money than you i think
is because denzel has paid thousands of
pounds
to james armstrong today no no so let me
no no
that's not exactly that's right that's
not why but i don't know why you're
trying to put it against him but
let me tell you this let me tell you oh
no no no no i know you don't want to
hear it i'm going to end you last time
because you're so wrong
but let me say my thing you can tell me
why i'm wrong but this is my theory okay
you tell me if i'm wrong but i think
it's very
very very um you know this is not
opinions it seems obvious listen
denzel's made more money than you
probably you just said that denzel has
paid james armstrong for mentoring
you haven't i think denzel is more
successful because he paid james for
mentoring
james is my student james is my student
so so he's getting information that's
why he's successful and i think that you
would be more successful if instead of
calling me a fake guru and trying to
pick holes or whatever
if you actually said let me just learn
from this guy i think you'd be more
successful than that so um
again okay now here's where you went
wrong um
i you believe in focus like
yeah focus so so if you want to um so
for example you focus in on property
to become where you get to where you are
today you focus on the property
you diversify you've got courses you've
got all these so you focus on property
yep
now i'm at that stage in life where i'm
thinking you know what the youtube thing
is going well for you yeah the personal
fans thing is going well for me
how about and you know you see my tick
tock it's doing well doing really well
respect them so i thought you know what
it would make more sense for me to focus
more on that and then come back into
property game later as a
developer fair enough that's totally
fair but here's what's not fair
to then teach property number i made
that course when i was when i haven't
seen
to teach property based on having one sa
my experience is my spirit and a free
course by the way i know that's fine but
in my opinion
and with disclaimers as well and with
disclaimers yeah my opinion
but here's my opinion okay my opinion is
to teach a course whether it's free
whether it's paid for whether it's on
youtube whether it's on your channel but
to teach something
that you haven't really got a proven
track record in i think
is wrong i think it's misleading
say if i was a student yeah you taught
me yep and i made the course based on
the information you taught me yeah and
my experiences yeah is that cool
nope you need if you're teaching you
need to have done it i don't know
that's also i'm a student i've got my
first essay no but okay
good question i think to teach something
i think you i i think to teach property
it's a very complex thing it needs it
needs training to set up a training
course whether it's free or whatever
i think that you need to have
legitimately done it made money in it
for at least a few years before you
start teaching people
in a few years you think i think so yeah
i think you'd have made serious money i
think you need to be able to show that
you've made money
you need to have a proven record i don't
i don't see a problem with me
documenting my journey no i don't
there's no problem with that
but that's not what you did you you you
said here's a free property course
that's freeze right so you're running a
course you're teaching people
you're setting yourself up basically
based on my experiences with my first
assistant okay
now i'm explaining to you why i got out
of the same market because i'm trying to
focus okay so that's all sorted but do
you think people should be doing your
course
whether it's free or not from doing your
course based on
your one rental rent that you had to
hand the keys back to should people
really be doing that course
not that i had to i made it oh because
he wasn't making money i made i made the
businesses because it was losing money
so
no no no you understand people do that
course
yeah i i essay i'm teaching them how to
get an essay yeah but
no i'm no i'm teaching how to get an
essay yeah but
how together you can't make money in
service accommodation right now you
can't you don't know how
it's not just sa does hmos as well and
but bear man this is why it's a joint
venture course denzel's also done
required but denzel's only successful
because he
has done my students training so
denzel's my mentee's
mentee yeah
okay okay so so you're telling me you
don't take money from your training
company
you have to take your salary from it so
what do you spend your money on just
generally
i live a very basic life actually i live
in a decent housing producing car but i
i like this house i'll be right back
dude this isn't my house this is my my
company rents this my company revenue
all through your company yep smart smart
smart but listen these clothes
aren't expensive these shoes are
reasonably expensive they're gucci's
with these are a good i don't buy gucci
i don't do bling bling yeah yeah
i travel i put it back to myself my
personal development
i like the way you've got you've gone a
lot so much appreciate it bro appreciate
a personal trainer but i don't i don't
live
i don't live a flash life i don't spend
too much money i pay myself ten thousand
pounds a month and that's from my
property training
that's from my property company my
property training company i don't take
your salary from that right now
is making no money what property um
training yep but two weeks ago
you did that you did the deal master
class 2000 people nine nine 19 people
correct that's making money no it's not
that's that's that's that's
uh turning over money
i'm doing training and charging for it
yeah for sure but right now i'm not
making any money
where's that door that's that's because
there's not loads of money in training
believe it or not
it's not
um about 20 20 yeah okay that's that's
pretty good
yeah that's right i mean you reinvest it
back in the proper team and i'm growing
you know my property business is growing
my training company is growing
yeah but a lot of the stuff i do like
next month bro i'm spending the whole
month working with 10 people
on uh helping them with their property
journey it's part of a show
called the eviction that's that's
costing me money to do it they're not
paying
that's just all of my training people
don't pay they okay after they've
received loads of value
they then might go you know what i'd be
doing them a disservice not to offer
advanced training but my courses the
online courses are 995.
the physical courses are are two about 2
000 generally
and then if you do everything together
all the contracts all the training all
the mentoring for a year
it's it it's about 10 grand plus fat
that's that that's that's it
so what's the issue i want to move on
from the course but that's
my final piece of advice i just you know
just so
i personally feel like i know you might
you have to take it but i just
personally feel like you should just
check the financial situation properly
before yourself you know getting people
to get into debt but you
because you know this is not because
because because you know not everyone's
as good as you
because yes there are no money down
deals but let's be real
do you think the average person can come
out and just get no money down deal
because they do every week they come on
my youtube average person
average not winners wednesday the
average person because wednesdays are
average people
no they're winners the winners that's
why i don't know when they're
they're winners but they're average
people they're from normal backgrounds
working a lot of them work in class
started with nothing and now they're
winning because they've been on my
training
look take how you want it just be
careful people are saying
a lot of bad things about you bro i
don't like you no i'm i'm
i'm the middle man okay no no no no no
no no i'm projecting
this clip bay i already explained this
all these people saying bad things about
me probably most of them have agendas
like yours
okay so then why is your company samuel
leeds
limited has two ccjs totally over twenty
thousand pounds i've talked about this
it came out it was two like two days ago
so just explaining experience that i'm
not
getting them yeah i've talked about this
i've talked about it again
again talk again but but listen speak
listen listen you can go through and you
can ask me this there's
many things i've talked about but that
means people are does that matter okay
okay ccjs that means people are having
problems with your services
so spring spring speak for yourself yeah
i've i've had i've had thousands and
thousands of customers i've got a lot
a lot of tenants i've got a lot of
different things and i have had a couple
of ccjs that i've actually been
incorrect i've had the court actually
confirming that and i've published that
and i've spoken about that that's one of
the things that really takes me off
actually
sorry i'll tell you one of the things
really kicks me off is when people do
videos
you know and they'll and they'll do it
an exposed video or a clickbait video or
whatever you call it clickbait a
clipboard video on me
and they'll take things out of context
and they'll talk about me and trump in a
really bad light and then what happens
is
i'll respond and go actually like the
ccj's like the bad reviews like this
like that like actually
hey folks there's a legitimate reason
here's what it is and i'll put out the
legitimate reason
and then people like you jump on the
bandwagon
don't look at the facts call me a fake
guru
to try and get more views but then
actually when i ask you why you can't
give me anything hello
okay that's there's a difference between
clickbait and supposing like
what shafted that's straight up
perspiration that's he's going to kick
back that's
that's he's going at you that's
clickbait yeah
the thumbnail was clickbait but me my
video has nothing to do with you sorry
i know you're big but you're headed up
to you but you still called me a figure
and that was not true it was again it's
just for you know it's just for clicks
you know the youtube game works okay you
know it works but i think it's unethical
okay if if that's unethical yep
are you telling me everything you've
done best on ever cause on the same
wavelength what i do is i am obviously
not perfect
but i have a very good product and
service i look after my clients okay
yeah
that's a good that's a good customer
very very happy that's a good one that's
a good answer that's a good answer
that's a good answer that's a good
answer
it's just again you know i personally
believe like for rent friend i advise
people to start five grand
i don't i
anything with respect you haven't got
the credibility
to advise people and that's my issue
i think you should just stick to your
what you're good at and and down the
line if you build
a property portfolio and you become
successful great maybe teach it
but get some traffic okay but then
what's stopping me from lying and saying
i have a property portfolio
well that'll be unethical
so then yeah so that's what i'm saying
just in the same line i'm not suggesting
you like i first
look what they want to know is they want
proof because a lot of people would like
to doubt you
how do you deal with the hate well i i i
it's like this
i just i just i just i just say well
let's talk yeah but not
obviously for my situation not everyone
normally haters will not come to talk to
me they want to come to
me so how like how do you deal with it
seen online now all right how are you
doing let me tell you something
there's a lay day she's probably
watching this right now called andrea
harbour
yeah andrea harbor i met her about two
and a half years ago yeah
she came to my crash course she then
paid two thousand pounds to go to the
deal finding extravaganza
at the deal finally extravaganza she
found out that she had cancer
and she had probably not long to live
i walked with her through the strategies
she's now cancer-free
she said the thing that stopped her
being so panicked was the fact that she
had
applied my training and she had a
passive income coming from property she
took the advice
she's now got multiple hmos and she's
making her passive income and she's
financially independent
that's what i look at jl spooner my very
first ever student
2013.
no fourteen november 2014 jail spooner
she was living in the council flat
she had no money she's just been living
in hostels and stuff she came to my
property investors crash course free
course now i think she might paid a
small very small amount
she came to the course as a direct
result of the course
she ended up buying her council flat she
raised money she bought a commercial
property that's turning over a million
pounds a year that's good
we're good friends today jasmine um
um james armstrong you know he's not my
mentor by the way
okay but he's he's you did say what so
it was a joint course i think he he
tapped that yeah
yeah fair enough i mean listen we can
argue about where he went to wherever he
is but okay fine but james answered the
same story
he um i met him he was an electrician's
apprentice
he was 19. he wasn't making great money
i believed in him he got into debt he
did he
got into serious debt he didn't tell me
i didn't find that until later but he
got into debt
i worked with him trained him he became
financially independent
he's now making um in excess of ten
thousand pound a month
he's now dating my frigging
sister-in-law
right but but but like so that you ask
me how i deal with the hype
what i look at is i look at my success
students i look at my
what are my customers saying not trolls
online not clickbait what are my
customers saying
what are my staff saying what's my
family saying my wife my kids you said
that most of your haters
don't even pay for your stuff i don't
know i l i just look at my customers
okay if i look at my customers i can see
the feedback forms that that's what i
look at i look at
my family what are my family saying
what's my church saying what
what am i saying so i don't i don't
understand with you you get haters
yeah and you're going to probably get
more as you can teach the youtube videos
and do tick-tock videos and
and whatever and hopefully you won't
click back people i suggest you don't do
that but fine
but but but but you know my advice is
don't worry about what people are saying
if it's not true
if it's true then they're a critic and
you should listen to them but when
people are saying stuff that's not true
then i would say just look at what your
actual customers are saying and i think
that's how
that'll be my advice to someone that's
dealing with haters because i haven't
had a smear campaign
which you probably know i have had bad
media press but
actually what's the truth what are my
customers saying
what are my results every week i have
people coming on on my youtube channel
with so i think that's what i focus on i
believe what you focus on expands
if i spent my whole time talking with
people like you about whether i'm a
scour
like i don't do it all the time i focus
on i appreciate you
no no and listen respect for actually
you know
coming on because most people would just
say samuel's a fake guru or samuels with
this and then i'll say oh let's talk
then and then they'll disappear
yeah you're the actually the very first
person the only person
so you know a little bit of respect
there but um but but
but but serious though because people
don't people just throw things around
and that's why i don't listen to it i
don't think it's legitimate
you know so that that that that's why i
do what i do and listen as i say
like i'm i'm i'd be happy to have this i
think that
i know i know i've said i don't think
you should be running a tr teaching
people about property
or running training events whether it's
free or whether it's not free but i
respect what you've done on tick tock
and i respect i don't know you've done
it you've got other side hustles going
on stuff
you're young so hopefully you know
you're going to
succeed me i'll be happy hopefully
you'll pay for my training
i'll give you one i'll get you on the
train one day yeah
you know okay you know what it is um i
know
okay this is another question and people
will know um that you want to know
no but i'm the middleman i'm just trying
to like you said i was a favorite
i'm talking to you right now all right
okay okay i'll ask you then um
obviously i already know the reason why
i'm but um at 23 you was
doing illusionist i already know the
reason why but it was explained you know
yeah and i've talked about this i mean
my dad was a magician i worked for him
for a few months
professionally and uh my brother went on
to have an entertainment agency
and i i i and i occasionally used to do
some shows mostly for charity
uh my last show was when i was probably
yeah probably about 23 which would have
been about
what like six six years ago now um which
is actually a charity
a charity yeah it's just like people
thought about um you know
your property investor why are you doing
that
but but but sure um but if you think
that a property investor all they do is
property then you're wrong
yeah no i just wanted you to clear out
yeah yeah it's just some
yeah but you know that's good though but
um so
also i know i don't i know you don't
know talk about the castle but
no i'm happy about castle i'll tell you
about it people think
they made a wrong judgment okay you know
you know i think it's not commercially
viable
for well it's got a gross development
value of 6.35 million pounds i bought it
for 800 grand
so there's a lot a lot to do it's going
to be a long process
what's the point what's the actual
platform i'm going to turn it into
luxury apartments and houses
i've currently got planning permission
um and the current
gross development value six point three
five million and i'm trying to push that
up
oh okay to eight million yes but we'll
say okay
we'll say but it's it's a good project
and i'm learning a lot from it so
yeah okay no regrets there's definitely
a headache yeah
i think yeah just some when you document
it just
just be yeah just be truthful just yeah
i i i've documented the castle i've
spoken about it
and uh yeah also so
you see the financial freedom channels
don't good videos yeah bang individuals
yeah but it's just for that
fake name yep you're making a brand new
company out of nowhere
yeah and you're getting deals and i as i
go in my return journey i noticed that
you know
even with having a three-month-old
company they'll see it as pretty young
you know yeah so how do you get past the
credit good question yes
um okay so my financial freedom
challenges um
i did i set up a brand a brand new spank
new company called lucas ruby limited
glasses wig fake identity yeah
and that's in that week maybe you could
call me a fake whatever you want to call
me but
you know disguise and the reason i did
that though the reason the reason i was
in disguise was only because
the reason i did the financial freedom
challenge was because i wanted to
empower people
and i wanted to show people actually if
you're starting out from scratch i want
to take away everyone's excuse
and say even with a new identity a new
company i can still get deals
um starting again from scratch that was
the reason i did it so in terms of the
sorry go on
yeah so what people say is that yeah
did you fake it i didn't fake it i had
to i went by an alias name
because if i if this is kind of like
damned if you if you had gone in and i'd
gone
hey i'm samuel leeds what's happening
now and i got a deal everyone would have
gone oh but you only got a deal because
you signed your leads
that's true i agree so i went in with a
different identity with a disguise
still got the deal yeah right still got
the deal and now everyone's thinking
geez if he can do it as lucas ruby with
that stupid wig on
hit i can do it so the purpose of it was
to empower inspire people it was
completely legitimate
nothing was nothing was um made up it
was a gym i actually had a referee
oh really no but no but what you're
missing is on
yeah how do you pass credit checks
like you know you made a brand new show
how are they giving you okay so the
timing of it good question the timing of
that i think another video you're
talking about in sheffield when i
secured
the timing of it was i secured the deal
handshake got it great then when we do
the paperwork and not
with that lady because you this is a
people business she i sorry she she
saw your like charisma she like believed
in you and she's spoken about this
because people even like
gone after her yeah i don't know trying
to get dirt trying to discredit
dude so many people have tried to
discredit yeah so many people and no one
can
because it's legitimate so so i got the
deal i screwed the deal
i didn't sign it in lucas ruby i signed
it at samuel lee
but when i signed it i had already
secured it
so it was like it was all done actually
yeah yeah it wasn't done in a fake name
but when i went through the paperwork i
said that i think the little things like
that you know
i feel like just little explanation i
think because that's what yeah but
that's what builds all these like
haters you know i don't think it does
you think they'll hurt you regardless
yeah
they don't hate me because they're
unsure about how they're trying to find
a reason they're trying to find fault
yeah so whatever i do they're going to
try and find fault
okay no no no not fair not fair enough
so then
cool if i'm not okay so if i'm not like
you know
you say i'm not credible to teach of
course yeah what do you
suggest i do then no oh it's just you
don't teach courses on property teach
what you
teach courses on on uh affiliate
marketing because you're really good at
that
yeah you make money doing that yeah you
know i see your videos
you got adsense so you're getting paid
when people watch videos then in the
description
yeah you've got like you should really
turn your up why don't you not turn it
on
turn my ads on yeah why not dude it's
actually an admin problem right now
i didn't run my ads for years just
because i didn't want to because i
didn't want i didn't want people to
think
i'm trying to run my youtube channel
just to try and get adsense i'm like no
i'm just vlogging my journey
okay but then in time i was like
actually you know what i turn my ads on
because i'm not financially [ __ ]
turn my ads on just do it i turn my ads
on
my about five thousand dollars but then
they were like oh you need a pen
oh okay i need a pin and i just haven't
bothered to do it so right now there's
no ads on my channel as far as i'm aware
um but listen i'm not being funny but
that's small money to me because i'm
doing
million pound deals and you know okay so
now
you'll calm down which makes more money
now
which makes you more money the training
or the problem
that makes you money because you you
know that's your personal name yeah
then like as an as a tool like as in
okay so to be honest
so oh well so so far this year we're now
in october
we have made no money from training
when i'm talking about money by the way
i'm talking about profit profit profit
okay first four years of training we
made no we made no money
2018 that's nothing we did yeah yes that
was the big big big
yeah we did make money okay so like
just those houses i just showed you i've
made hundreds of thousands of pounds on
that
i've been doing flip something so i'm
making quite a lot of money in property
that's how i'm funding
things that's how i'm living in nice
houses and okay this is rented fine
but but that's how so yeah i mean geez
listen if the training business suddenly
just
starts making loads of money i have no
problem with that i'd go because i
believe that when people pay you it's a
certificate of thanks
yeah so if i'm making a lot of money as
a trainer i would say it's because i'm
good at it there's no issues with that
as it happens i'm not making money with
my training company which i'm okay with
as well because i do it because i
it's for me it's my it's my mission and
i i set up my training company
didn't make money for four years it's a
mission thing for me
yeah i mean i can't argue that you mean
i don't know your your
your your own company your stuff so fair
enough
no i this is more for a personal finance
standpoint come on
people say you're this big you know
property guy why do you rent
i'm not i'm not getting on to you but i
just want you to explain it to them yeah
like why do you want to
say your question so this house room
right now nice house right yeah yeah
cheers man i appreciate that this is
rented yeah um
my hat my personal house this this is uh
this is not where i personally this is
where
we have studio and different things my
brother lives here um
my purse house i rent the reason i rent
it is because
i don't like putting my money into stuff
that's not an asset
okay so if i had to buy something i.e
this house could argue it isn't that's
it because it's a studio and stuff but
whatever
i don't want to sink money into
something that's not giving me a return
yeah okay so i'm happy to sink money
into stuff but i think like the castle
for instance i sunk a lot of money into
that
the land of something i bought that all
cash but i'm doing it because i'm
thinking it's an asset it's going to
give me money back even if it's going to
be one day
whereas where i'm living is not going to
give me money back so i'll rent it so
you'll see me
renting opportunity costs putting money
elsewhere to make dude even my clothes
the reason i don't
wear expensive clothes i am frugal like
if it's not tax deductible i ain't
dropping a lot of money what were your
cars i said i see the really interesting
areas all right
my range over it i do own that okay i
think it i think it is on finance so i
didn't buy it all at once
from memory um i do own the range rover
but i wouldn't advise someone to do that
yeah
i i'm going to listen i think lisa and i
would i agree
i would lease your car um i would also
lease a cheaper car than you need
i'd live below you means when
something's tax-deductible go crazy
yeah claim it back yeah yeah my training
people can claim it back
i'm like yeah yeah yeah it's smart so
but if it's not tax deductible and it's
not going to give you any return
i would say you've got to be really
frugal yeah so my clothes i tried it
i tried getting my clothes tax
deductible by putting my name on it and
stuff
then get it run past the hmrc so i was
like forget it i'm gonna i'm gonna now
go cheap again so these that's one of my
clothes you'll never see me
not never even jewelry and stuff i just
yeah yeah
okay fair enough and um you know
you think okay cool
would you say um so you see all that
chaff and all these people
do you think they're just they're just
out to get you i don't know i don't
know i didn't know why when you said
fake guru i didn't i was out to get you
okay but i i can't i can't know what's
in someone's head i only know what's in
my head
yeah that's why we came here to talk
about yeah yeah does that lie
yeah well i i rate that though you know
he came became correct he came correct
i'll be wrong um
is there any like you know final words
you want to say to the people you know
the haters whatever you know i would
just say check
facts check [ __ ] check facts and
there's a lot of
people with opinions but just check
facts if you're going to go on a
training course make sure that the
trainer
is actually credible uh and doing it and
says they're doing it
uh check facts believe in yourself and
um
and also don't worry too much like like
in in terms of
listen i think you're a fake euro right
i said that
however if someone can learn from bits
and bobs of your tick tock in your
channel
great rather than thinking like is this
person you know
but here's what i'm saying be a student
of many and a follower of none
yeah um further what to come at your
point about me being fake
yeah i don't go around anywhere like
telling anyone i'm a
property expert i'm uh you know i don't
i don't claim that okay
i just thought you know what my
followers they want to get into property
they see me get my rent to run i thought
you know what let me teach them as well
i can't be also applied to so many dm's
i just think it's dangerous when people
teach based on very little experience
because i think that you need to have
been in the game a little while before
you start advising but listen i'm not
here to bash you or anything like that
one one could say that you know the
experience and um
stuff that i taught in that course is
based from you know people like yourself
or from
my other mentors you know yeah by james
armstrong
[Laughter]
call it i don't do the guy i don't i
don't tell you that he says it on your
side maybe he's denzel
who makes more money than you because
he's got james james no it's not i
already explained to you i
diversified i'm not into property as
much as i was
but um again um you know with the um
essay again you take l's you bounce back
from them simple as just like your
castle you take l's you bounce back from
them i'm pretty sure
i hope i really hope it does go well
yeah things are going pretty good
you just don't yeah because people will
say like though
i even have you have stalkers you may
have stalkers right probably
like they'll drive past it and um
they'll say oh they didn't hear any
construction look why has it got to that
point people
i don't know you're asking me why is
this person a stalker and why is this
person i hate him i'm like
i'm not going to sign up for that class
jim rohn says that jimmy says don't sign
up for that class
but i could try and work out why did
this person say that why but all it's
going to do is drive me insane
all i can focus on is me my family my
staff my customers
and make sure they're making money
they're winning and they're happy which
they are yeah
that's good just doing it for your
family yeah and my staff and my students
and
yeah yeah they're all winning i so yeah
i just think um
you know so we establish
you know you're talking about you're in
a property game you do it
i think going forward just
just don't take the rest but just try to
like you know
relax with the no money down deals i
mean i know it's doable
i know it's doable but you know again
average person do you think that as
creative enough to
you know what have the connections yeah
you know what when i started i had no
money
and i i'm so grateful
for the strategies like lease option
agreements like deal packaging
you know this this this joint this big
deal i just showed you the land
six houses built half a million profit
although and they're about
that was a joint venture i put all the
money in my joint venture partner is
making
six figures profit he didn't put a penny
of his own money in
no because he has a skill set and he has
the knowledge he has the knowledge if
you have the
knowledge and you have the network and
you have the belief
i don't believe money should be a
barrier okay no i agree i like that
that's a good that's a good closing
statement that's good
but yeah man so to conclude am i fake
guru i think you are a fake euro
in the property industry yeah but i
don't claim to be a property expert
i'd say i would argue that you do by
having a property course
no no if i say i'm a property expert i'm
claimed to be on property yes but just
because of a course it doesn't mean
okay okay now
i wouldn't over this course of this
interview yeah you have shown me that
you know
you know you know what you're talking
about
are you a fake guru no you you've
slightly convinced me like maybe
you you do you maybe you do a little bit
of what you talk about i think
you've only convinced me you haven't
convinced i don't think you've convinced
me
you know what you can never convince
everybody
there's a sanctuary you're everybody's
cup of tea you might as well be a mug
that's true no i agree i agree i agree i
agree it's just about just
i feel like go ahead and be more a
little bit more in my opinion truthful
yeah but that would imply that i'm being
untruthful which is not true that's
incorrect
okay no i'm not going to argue it's just
about i think with your videos
you do post a lot in it so i post a lot
i give a lot of value i give a lot of
truthful
honest legitimate advice that helps
thousands and thousands of people
yeah i know i i respect that no
definitely even you know i went to your
quest course
was it good this time it lost your
impact this time cool was it good
yeah it's just oh sorry
oh man these batteries run out
yeah but um
can i get some questions from you i
think we've i think we're probably done
man
if i'm honest it's been a it's been a
long one but i'm happy to chat again
yeah i'm happy to chat again
well guys that's that's confronting some
new leads
i hope i've asked all the questions you
guys wanted you know i try my best
like i said you're right you do you do
not know how to talk abroad well
it's just it's just i'm just giving
facts and that's why most people won't
do it
because most people won't meet with me
because they know
that they they're either they know
they're wrong or they just don't know so
they might come saying i don't know if
you're a [ __ ] or not because i haven't
checked the facts or they'll check the
facts and they'll say actually he's not
no one's ever going to come and meet me
and argue me and prove me that i'm a
fake guru or i'm a scammer
because i'm just not lots of people will
comment it on bot trolls and different
things but
but it's not true and i think it's wrong
and i think it's damaging
um and disrespectful and unethical and
illegal
the defamation yep even what you said
i could potentially see you for what for
saying
fake guru and having a picture of me i
could potentially see you for that
yeah and why would you do that wow i
probably wouldn't
because i couldn't be bothered but if i
really wanted to
i'd have to speak to my solicitors but i
reckon i'd have a pretty strong case
you say that when you you know but but
anyway we've spoke now so you know
it's all good that's also good it's just
i have backup as well but yeah cool
um you have what backup backup
yeah but if you're wrong legally you're
wrong legally in the world
and you still lose if you're wrong we'll
see but anyways
but we won't say because i'm not going
to see it but my point is it's illegal
to say things about people that aren't
true is is actually illegal
so yeah i'm just saying it's not only
unethical you see i'm
like again i'm the man i'm i'm the voice
for people i don't want to
see but the problem is though there's
too many middle men
trying to shed light trying to but
actually what they're doing is they're
saying things that are untrue unverified
for their own personal gain that's why
we're here to like yeah and it's wrong
so we're here and i respect you for
coming down yeah
but yeah guys you know that's that's the
live stream confronting some of your
leads
hope you guys enjoyed it and then um
yeah
it's pokey backs baby
thank you i hope you um
so yeah man but yeah just now you're a
good person though you're good i
appreciate that man
did it guys expected by the way yeah a
little bit i mean
i was expecting i was expecting them i i
i gave you all the questions
nice he's on
it was definitely a confrontation
yeah do you record it for your channel
yeah yeah we recorded it we'll send you
the footage
okay well you're uploading there i don't
know what we're gonna do with it
we do a video every single day but what
i won't do is i won't take it all out of
context
but i mean it's on your channel anyway
you know people can see it
yeah people can see it
[Music]
yeah you know what i think we've rent to
rent um
i mean yeah we've we've run up we've run
a training program called rent to rent
accelerator
i think it's like 500 pounds
um but but again as i said i'd always
suggest start with the free stuff
oh no obviously